hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from the Polish League
it was around 5 and it is pental Hare
Krishna versus Vaseline manchuk and it's
a game I really wanted to show for a
couple of days now but the position in
question is so complicated I just had to
cap keep the engine running for a few
days um in order to truly crunch the
numbers I'm exaggerating a little bit as
usual but not by much so now let's check
it out if you're interested only in the
position you can go to that moment but
it's like it's main Theory uh and then
um the the positioning question so I I
urge you to check it out especially if
you play the slav defense or play
against the slav defense uh you will
learn to avoid this in your own games
because it could happen so D4 by Hari
Krishna with D5 by vasel C4 I'm going
for the Queen's Gambit and the last
little declines it by going for the slav
defense we have knighted to C3 Knight to
F6 and now C characters on D5 this is uh
the the main move with Bishop to F4 and
unite the C6 and D3 so every move is a
top move that current theory supports A6
and now Bishop to D3 is the mainline
Bishop to E2 Okay the third most popular
option with Bishop to F5 Knight to F3
and now Pawn to E6 so the bishop is out
of the cage you're gonna close the light
squares with Queen to B3 putting
pressure on B7 and Rook to A7 looks
weird but again it is the top move uh
everyone plays here with knights the E5
Knight captures an E5 Bishop captures
and Knight to D7 attacking the bishop
now sometimes people just continue
developing Rook C1 you could also move
the bishop back to G3 uh pentala castles
and now
uh in normals or Knight captures an E5
and also Queen to B6 offering a queen
trade is a known move but here yeah
Evancho plays a pawn to B5 and it is now
already as of move 12 then we have a
completely new game and now look at this
Rook after D1 uh Queen to A8 uh very
nicely
uh putting the queen on this along
diagonal and now Rook 8 to C1 we have
Knight captures and E5 D captures and
Bishop to E7 here uh eventually prepares
the castle but Hari Krishna stops him
and he plays Knight captures on B5 and
uh okay
um the Evancho has been playing this
um opening his entire life and nothing
really new happened here nothing weird
is happening it's just a peace sacrifice
that should not exist but okay you're
getting two pawns for the piece so maybe
that in itself can justify the sacrifice
you will have the two connected pass
pawns on the queen side and uh you know
uh maybe if black plays the perfect game
you're not gonna you're not gonna win
but uh yeah you have good chances so a
captures on B5 Bishop captures on B5 and
King to f8 okay Avast also lose uh loses
castling privileges but look at this now
pentala Hare Krishna plays the bishop to
C6 and he was in this position on move
18 that vasel ivankuk resigned the game
as seemingly there is nothing more to be
done here and what's even weirder okay
Hari Krishna spent a little bit more
time this is a classical game he had
some 45 47 minutes on the clock uh
evanchuk had over an hour he had an hour
and 15 minutes on the clock so he
basically spent no time getting to this
position
uh but now after uh this uh peace
sacrificed by by Hari Krishna and uh
seemingly him losing a lot more material
he decided to resign now it's not uh
clear why but uh okay we could show you
cannot go to B8 okay that square is not
available for the queen you cannot go to
E8 that square is covered by the bishop
so what can you do you can play Queen to
C8 or queen to d8 queen to C8 isn't that
spectacular because you align the queen
with the rook and C1 so just Bishop to
B7 attacks the queen and next move Rook
to C8 is coming you will lose the queen
and even if you play Queen to D7 okay
your queen will not get scared uh still
Rook the CH check and after Bishop to d8
there's a queen to B for with check and
after King the E8 there's Bishop to C6
and you you lose your queen uh so you
can't do that and if you go King to G8
then comes and even
um uh more terrifying move and that is
uh Queen to d uh D6 and that's all there
is there's no way to
uh save this if you capture the queen
it's not great just e captures and you
cannot defend the bishop and also
Checkmate is being threatened so you're
gonna suffer a severe material loss here
you have to gonna you're gonna have to
make some room for your king You're
Gonna Lose the bishop after King G7 Rook
captures on h8 King captures or you
capture here but I mean nothing
um is really worth it now D7 and you
cannot stop promotion so you are dead
lost here if after Bishop to C6 you you
play Queen to ca2 cannot go King to a
queen to be it you cannot go Queen to
see it you cannot go Queen to E8 only
move that uh remains this uh Queen to d8
so surely a a player of
um uh Evancho's caliber would consider
Queen to d8 uh the problem is even if
you consider Queen today is still it
it's still lost for white unless you
find one very specific move that comes
um after after a lot of moves that I
haven't played so I'm going to show you
what this means Bishop to B7 okay
everyone sees this so of course we want
to win the black queen you have to play
Queen to A5 and now after Bishop Rook to
see it with check you have to block with
the bishop okay Bishop to d8 so everyone
everyone sees this this is not a problem
uh Evancho probably saw all of this in
in a fraction of a second because he's
just that good but now comes Bishop to
A6 now you're clearing the B file for
the queen to reach the B8 square and now
how do you stop just The Rook captures
on d8 well you play Rook captures on A6
and after Queen to B8 now threatening
Rook captures and d8 you play King the
E7 and now after Queen the B7 check and
King to E8 you play Rook D to C1 now
with some terrible threats of Rook
capture 78 then the other rule comes up
the board and wins the queen or even
more plainly just Rook capture 78
followed by Queen captures an A6 and
there is one move here that you had to
see all the way back when you played
Queen to d8 in order to realize that
this is actually playable and I'm not
gonna show it to you I'm actually going
to ask you to pause the video here and
uh and try to find this movie because
I'm asking you to find it from this
position not from the position where
Evancho resigned so feel free to pause
the video and try to find the absolute
strongest move for black while I give
you a couple of seconds
foreign
I just don't believe you I do not
believe you found this movie it's
probably maybe the the first or the
second time since I've been making
videos that I do not believe anyone
found this move but uh if if you
actually found it then you have bragging
rights and if anyone tells you you're
not a great chess player you just show
them this video and tell them I found
this move the move in question is Bishop
the C2 this is the move that you have to
find in order to actually continue
playing this game uh from the position
where vassal resigned now some people
wouldn't resign some people would you
know okay show me the win show me that
you have everything worked out but not
Evancho Evancho he's a gentleman and
because he didn't see Bishop to C2 in
the position where he resigned he
thought there is nothing and it's best
to resign you know be be a true
gentleman of Chess now the reason why
Bishop to C2 is so powerful is that you
you disconnected the white Rooks and you
cannot capture the bishop if you capture
with this Rook then you get checkmated
Queen T1 on his Checkmate so obviously
we're going to try capturing with the
other Rook but if you capture with the
other Rook bear in mind black is still
up a full Bishop so now you simply have
to trade Queen B6 and now after the
queen moves you're gonna play Rook day
seven and there's no way for white to
continue the attack once white makes a
few moves uh because there there's
nothing forcing here you will play King
E7 and now once a move is made because
white has no more attacking moves you
will play Rook to E8 You'll Play King to
f8 you you will have successfully
artificially castled King side and there
is nothing more to worry about so you're
just gonna be up a piece uh and that's
it so Andrew Bishop to C2 the only move
that keeps the tension for white is
Queen to B8 but uh it doesn't do a lot
now black plays haunted D4 and this is
uh I mean to see Bishop to C2 in
combination with a pawn to D4 which
frees up the E4 Square so the bishop
controls A8 so you can play
I I mean I'm not exaggerating when I
said that no one finds this like no one
finds this even the great vastly
manchuku if uh if if you said that
there's a position that no one can solve
that the engine cannot solve that Magnus
cannot solve I would say give it to give
it to vastly when he will find it he on
a good day vasel will find uh
uh such a move but obviously this was
not a good day for wasley manchuk and
the problem is now let's say you play
Rook capture 78 again you're down
material you can't go for this if Queen
capresent the eight yes you can go Queen
to B5 with check you will pick up the
Rook here but after King a fake queen
captures on A6 uh but it's not a problem
Pawn to D3 and uh I mean you're you're
done a bishop black has a pass Pawn
already uh ready to go to D2 there's no
uh coming back from this so after D4
you're gonna have to play e Captain D4
it's not an attractive move but it's the
best white has and now Bishop to E4 and
now once you want this Rook lands on um
A8 that's it for white the attack has
completely evaporated white will of
course throw in a nice B4 because it's
the strongest move and after Queen to D5
you have to keep defending the bishop
here there is nothing better Rook d8 is
coming you have to trade here Rook
captures Queen captures and after Rook
the C8 winning the black queen you don't
care King these seven now you force
white to take your queen and after Rook
capture 78 Rook captures 98 and queen to
B5 check nicely connecting with the rook
and A6 you just move the Rook to C6
where it's defended and you have two
Rooks and a bishop for a queen you are
objectively completely winning
so uh yeah I know that uh from this
position from Bishop to C6 where vassal
resigned the game and move 18 to this
position this is move 31 so you would
have to see some
uh you know uh 12 13 moves in advance
but uh they're not just any moves
they're they're moves that uh I mean uh
okay you could find this you could find
this you could find this but then even
uh finding this bishop to see to move
incredible then finding D4 bringing up
E4 for the bishop controlling A8 uh and
all of that uh and you still have to
give up your queen but uh in the end
after a rook to C6 your com Your
Position will be completely winning so
absolutely incredible and like I said
it's uh of course not taking anything
away from pental Hare Krishna he he
crushed vastly manchuk in 18 moves and
it's I mean he uh is one of the
strongest players uh who who never
became world champion everyone knows
that he was the you know the the fear of
the entire Chess World when he was young
he's now I believe 54 years of age uh
when he was like 20 uh if he said across
to you it doesn't matter if you were
carpool if you were Kasparov you you you
you feared for your life and uh even
today he he he can play a you know
brilliant brilliant game but here he
just didn't want to continue he just
didn't want to you know okay show me
show me how you beat me he didn't find I
believe I have no idea I believe that he
he didn't find the bishop to see to move
uh because he just didn't invest enough
at the time he he didn't waste any time
at all for this game he wasted 15
minutes he still had an hour and 15
minutes when he resigned in this
position which is uh I mean I I it just
makes me very sad because you know guys
how much I'll have um
if anyone it should should tackle this
position it is definitely him and he
would find all of this uh over the world
he would find all of this blindfold but
you know it for some reason this was not
this was not his day
uh so yeah
uh that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed it basically a miniature of 18
moves where Hare Krishna just crushed
vastly when chook would uh with a you
know a peace sacrifice for two pawns
that uh objectively doesn't do much but
you know it it caught him by surprise he
saw that okay no moves uh can be played
here nothing really works and he just
decided to resign uh but yeah if you're
if you play the slum if you play against
the slav maybe someone tries this
against you or you might price uh
something like this against someone uh
you know if it's a bullet or Blitz you
might get away with this with white but
this was classical and he got away with
it so you can play this and if you don't
know it people will play it against you
as that that's usually how it works yeah
that's the game I hope you guys enjoyed
it sorry about uh taking me a few days
to cover this but you know a lot is
happening in the world and also the
engine really needed to Crunch that
position it's not an easy position to
Crunch even for an engine uh so I once
again really hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank sachidar pitorapu also
treat Helga Matrix Jaylene
festival.org.gg from 15 to 21st of
October 2023 for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here and thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and once again uh you know
the biggest of high fives if you found
Bishop the C2 uh see you soon